hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
video I'm going to answer a question
from one of our readers Diana who was
asking me what she should major in at
college so she wrote in asking hello I'm
a subscriber to your newsletter and I
really enjoy them thank you I wanted to
know if you have any advice for me I'm a
college student with a passion for
design and business I already have sales
experience and love the business
industry I just can't decide what to
major in I was thinking of event
planning and majoring in business
management do you think it's an
enjoyable and lucrative occupation any
tips anything would be helpful maybe
other job ideas Thank You Diana so Diana
a couple things for you here in terms of
is it enjoyable to be in the event
management business that's completely up
to you right we all have different
things that we like and don't like I
know for me I wouldn't enjoy being an
event planner but for you it could be
the best thing ever so I'd really
encourage you to follow what you're
super passionate about and that will
lead you down the road of success in
terms of it being a lucrative career or
not the amount of money that you make as
an entrepreneur will be in direct
proportion how much value you can add to
your customers so look at the event
management business look at the types of
customers you're dealing with if you see
an opportunity for you to come in and
solve a real problem and add a lot of
value to helping your customers then
you'll be on your way to setting up a
very lucrative type of company in terms
of what to study in school business
management could be great it'll teach
you some of the skills that you need to
run your business I would definitely
look to see if there was an
entrepreneurship course or a small
business course you can sign up for what
I found really helpful when I was in
university was I partnered up with one
of my university professors and I
created my own course so at the time I
had my own business already and wanted
to use the resources of the university a
little bit to help me grow my business
because as an entrepreneur you want to
use everything you can to get your
business forward
so I partnered up with him and we
created our own course design and a lot
of it was around helping my business
grow and he supported that concept and
gave me a mark at the end of it and
there's no final exam which is fantastic
so I would love to see if you could
partner up with one of your professors
and create your own course to help you
grow a business
on top of that to see if event-planning
this for you or not I try to start my
own business part time and take on a
couple clients and see if you'd like
doing the business see if you're really
good at it see if you can add a lot of
value to your customers or partner up
with an event management business offer
your services on a part-time basis and
see if you enjoy doing it talk to the
owner try to add as much value as you
can try to be involved in the business
as much as you can and that way when you
are ready to start your own business you
have experience you know if you like it
or not you know you're really good at
and you're kind of hitting the ground
running so I hope that helps Diana if
you guys liked the video please give it
a thumbs up below and I'd also love to
hear thoughts and feedback if you want
to leave a comment underneath the video
and stay tuned for next episode